[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans le 7-8
loisirs ravi de vous retrouver pour
votre numéro dédié à vos idées sorties
tout de suite le sommaire de ce vendredi
1er juin amoureux des plantes ou curieux
à la recherche de conseils rendez vous
les 2 et 3 juin au domaine de madame
elisabeth à versailles nouvelle édition
de paroles de jardiniers rencontres
entre amateurs et professionnels
michael duval responsable du service
espaces verts du domaine sera avec nous
pour nous parler du programme de ces
deux jours il y à 50 ans le public
découvrait pour la première fois les
animaux en semi-liberté le parc
zoologique de thoiry ouvre ses portes et
propose l expérience inédite
il fait ce samedi 2 jean son
anniversaire avec le pape ni touahri
festival de nombreux concerts sont
prévus toute la soirée et avec les beaux
jours la nature reprend ses droits les
fleurs éclosent les arbres se parent de
leurs plus beaux feuillage pourquoi ne
pas fabriquer un herbier dans notre
rendez-vous junior mélanie pocket nous
montrera comment ce week-end la petite
reine sera à l'honneur sur le territoire
samedi de jean saint quentin en yvelines
organise la fête du vélo sur le parvis
de la gare à montigny le bretonneux
de nombreuses animations jusqu'à 18
heures et pour les amateurs de randonnée
vtt c'est la 23ème édition de la manif
ut ce dimanche 3 juin magny les hameaux
cinq circuits de 20 à 80 kilomètres
chaque année plus de 500 participants se
donnent rendez-vous départ au musée
national de port royal des champs
les distances sont complètement
différentes le 80 km on va jusqu'à
rochefort en yvelines
c'est quand même faut les faire parfois
les sortir les 80 pour le 20 km c'est
pour les familles les petits jeunes
on reste dans le sur le plateau dans le
coin et puis le reste en berne et sur
sur la vallée en vallée de chevreuse
forêt de rambouillet tout ce qui peut y
avoir à voir et surtout des côtes un
festival rural musical et familial c'est
la troisième édition de tracteurs blues
dans les yvelines
tout le week-end une programmation riche
gratuite ça commence ce vendredi soir à
guern avec différents groupes toute la
soirée et notamment le rock
psychédélique de tell tale signs
originaire de nashville
on laisse florence kowaleski responsable
communication nous présenter les
artistes qui se produiront samedi et
dimanche suivie d'un extrait de l'une
des formations samedi de juin en
aura-t-elle win bischoff food qui lui
vient de floride
il est considéré par la presse
spécialisée comme l'un des élus mais
relève 12 actuelle dimanche nous aurons
creek berkane et ellis hook qui devait
refaire 8,1 guitares punk et delta blues
et il sera accompagné par le chanteur de
blues et américains
[Musique]
je sais
g
[Musique]
jardiniers aguerris ou simples curieux
fait le plein d'idées pour prendre soin
de votre jardin ce week end le domaine
de madame elisabeth à versailles
accueille la nouvelle édition de paroles
de jardiniers avec nous michael duval
pardon responsable de l'événement et du
service espaces verts du domaine bonjour
bonjour camille alors parole de
jardiniers c'est un rendez-vous
relativement récent mais avec un
programme déjà bien fourni bien entendu
c'est la deuxième édition au domaine de
madame isabelle nous l'avons concocté
avec beaucoup d'animations
il faut savoir qu'aujourd'hui à partir
de ce week-end ce sont des exposants ce
sont des artisans locaux nous avons mis
un point d'orgue à trouver des artisans
des yvelines et de l'île de france mais
aussi beaucoup de surprises puisque nous
allons avoir des ruches connecter un
poulailler connectés mais aussi des
chefs cuisiniers qui vont aussi magnifié
les produits du potager compte y en aura
pour tous les goûts et c'est aussi un
lieu privilégié où dans lequel se
déroule l'événement le domaine de madame
elisabeth est ce qu'on pouvait nous nous
présenter en tripoli il eu deux belles
isabelle voilà pour ceux qui ne
connaissent pas c'est un parc de huit
hectares à deux pas du château de
versailles
il faut à peu près cinq minutes pour y
arriver 800 arbres vingt mille bulles
qui fleurissent au printemps une
orangerie une grotte une allée des
tilleuls magnifique roman c'est vrai
c'est tout pour les amateurs les
amoureux du jardin est ce qu ont vite se
promener ou même se reposer il ya une
grande richesse en beaucoup de variétés
différentes de plantes agissements qu'on
peut y voir parce qu'on peut en donner
quelques exemples mis tout à fait alors
effectivement dans les plantes ce qu'ils
sont amoureux des plantes pourront et il
boire et même touché un marronnier un
peu centenaire même complètement
centenaire on a un châtaignier corée vue
etc a vu madame elisabeth on voit là je
laisserai découvrir en allant visiter ce
week-end cet événement et on a un
séquoia magique et un cèdre du liban
donc il faut imaginer quelques 500 cèdre
du liban en france y ont encore un
exemplaire sur le domaine elisabeth soit
vraiment à voir et pour en savoir plus
sur madame elisabeth en personne un
spectacle neyret qui proposait oui tout
à fait là c'est la cerise sur le gâteau
cette année grâce à une association qui
va faire la béatification de madame
isabelle tourner
à monter cet événement un spectacle éric
d'une ricard vivent autour de madame
isabelle de sa vie de son oeuvre
donc voilà je pense qu'on va tirer un
petit peu de monde et des gens
passionnés aussi curieux de savoir qui
elle était pour en savoir plus et on
vous l'avait rappelé un petit peu en
début d'entretien il y aura des
animations proposées par votre service
le service des espaces verts du
département comme le troc de plantes des
visites guidées du parc et du potager
mais aussi une présentation de projets
innovants oui tout à fait alors cette
année nous avons mis un accent sur les
produits innovants autour du jardin nous
avons pour mission de valoriser nos
espaces autour des collèges en priorité
nos bâtiments départementaux et donc
nous avons trouvé comme moyen de faire
vivre ces espaces avec des produits
innovants comme un rucher connecter un
poulailler connecter à destination des
collèges donc des applications 2.0 pour
les petits et les grands
quand pourra les amateurs et puis même
le grand public découvrir ce week end
alors qu'est-ce que ça permet en full hd
connecté c'est un petit peu marrant
parce qu'effectivement aujourd'hui on a
tous notre téléphone portable est ce
qu'on a envie c'est d'avoir des
informations tournent ô de poule puis
imaginez notre poule avec des puces au
pied donc ça va faire pas mal aucun
problème
et à partir de cela on sait si elle va
pondre à neuf et ça va nous envoyer un
sms et un oeuf disponible et si toutes
les informations nécessaires autour de
ce coup là y est donc si riche
c'est amusant ça plaît aux enfants donc
c'est pour ça que ça fait un tabac
formant le jardinage effectivement
j'aime voir le jardinier
qu'effectivement avec les anciennes
méthodes mais aussi allié avec l'air du
temps et aussi de se confronter avec la
nouvelle technologie parce que le
charnier de demain devra se servir au
site de ces nouvelles technologies qui
n'est mis en oeuvre en fin de nuit un
autre dans la robotique etc un mot
également sur les ateliers culinaires
car ce sont aussi vos collègues un chef
cuisinier du département qui sont nés un
sa contribution lui c'est vrai qu'on
s'est attaché toujours maîtres de la
fourche à la fourchette et donc comment
peut-on magnifier les produits du
potager ou du jardin sans avoir un chef
cuisinier autres donc aujourd'hui c'est
à des sur ces manifestations et sur
parole de jardiniers ils vont concocter
des recettes faciles qu'on peut
rechercher chez soi et aussi pour les
grands enfants dont keith moussy
ils se sont donc ça plaît énormément en
plus on aura un super week-end donc tout
le monde pourra profiter
donc même si on n'est pas forcément
jardiner on peut venir découvrir
il ramène un stand à l'eau docteur qu'on
a appelés pour les gens qui sont un peu
perdus si une plante est malade si on a
besoin d'un petit peu de renseignements
parfait bon en tout cas merci beaucoup
michael douglas est revenue sur notre
plateau vous êtes donc attendus au
domaine de madame elisabeth jusqu'à ce
dimanche trois genres et toutes les
informations sont à retrouver sur notre
site internet merci encore michael duval
merci qui
c'est l'un des parcs zoologiques les
plus vastes de france le parc de thoiry
fête ses 50 ans cette année
inauguré le 10 mai 1968 c'était le
premier à proposer aux visiteurs de
découvrir les animaux en semi-liberté
pour son anniversaire l'équipe organise
un concert ce samedi de juin avec
notamment admirer claudio capéo retour
sur l'histoire du parc en images sans
quitter sa voiture un à lyon qui viendra
vous regardez il juge par la fenêtre
découvrir des animaux sauvages en
semi-liberté une première en france en
1968 paul de la panouse fils du
propriétaire du château de thoiry décide
de créer un parc zoologique unique en
son genre un circuit de 6 5 km parcours
la réserve où différents animaux de la
plaine africaine cohabitent
on dit parfois que les français manquent
d'imagination et notamment dans le
secteur du tourisme mais je pense que
pour une fois je veux pas nous a montré
que nous avons faire aussi bien que les
autres est même mieux puisque j'ai des
réserves africaines et je crois unique
en europe 50 ans et 22 millions de
visiteurs plus tard le célèbre safari
est toujours là mais le parc s'est
nettement a grandi plus de 750 animaux
sur 150 hectares sont désormais
présentés au public
au départ c'était vraiment la réserve en
voiture aujourd'hui on a énormément
étoffer la partie à pied
on a développé depuis un an ou deux les
activités plein air
avec la tyrolienne avec le safari air
park
on a fait un petit renouveau aussi dans
safari avec les camions safari des
activités toujours plus inventifs pour
conserver son côté révolutionnaire le
parc mise sur la modernité
pour fêter son demi siècle il lance la
première édition du happy touahri
festival samedi de juin
claudio capéo mais aussi à venir et
arcade yann se produiront dès 19h30
[Musique]
même si m
mois d'août
deux mois d'août 2
du
jours
[Musique]
qui lors d'une balade n'a jamais eu
envie de cueillir les fleurs et les
plantes souvent on ne sait pas quoi en
faire et certains réalisent les herbiers
de petit livre regroupant nos
découvertes une petite création que
mélanie a décidé de réaliser bonjour mme
hélène bonjour cabinet oui avec les
beaux jours de belles fleurs et feuilles
apparaissent du fils de résister même si
un herbier ça peut se faire toute
l'année
alors la première étape bien sûr c'est
de collecter les trésors on s'équipe de
nos chaussures et on part se balader
moi je les fais pas plutôt que ce matin
il faut bien sûr ouvrir les yeux et
ramasser ce qu'il nous plaît
et pour la suite en revanche il faut un
petit peu de matériel comme toute
activité manuelle finalement du papier
cartonné des feuilles blanches une paire
de ciseaux du scotch de la ficelle et
pour ceux qui veulent un herbier
perfectionner pourquoi pas du scotch
décoratifs et des feutres alors la
première étape importante pour le voit
c'est de faire sécher aplatir nos
récoltes on dispose les feuilles et
fleurs entre deux feuilles de brouillon
on place dessus un livre lourd et on
patiente alors ça peut être assez rapide
mais en général ça dure entre 1 et 2 jo
et une fois que c'est fait sur une
feuille blanche que j'ai choisi moi de
coupé en deux on scotch les feuilles
très important ensuite on note le nom de
la petite plante et pourquoi pas la date
et le lieu avec un petit commentaire
aussi pour que se crée un petit souvenir
et sans oublier bien sûr la décoration
et oui comme tout petit livre il faut
une couverture alors j'ai choisi des
teintes marron une très claire et une
foncé j'ai glissé à l'intérieur mais
feuille blanche on pis pour créer une
pochette on colle après j'ai tout
rassembler avec une ficelle vous allez
le voir sur les images la séquence je
colle je fais ma couverture
voilà j'ai fait des trous et ensuite on
décore alors on peut dessiner on peut
coller certaines aussi de nos écoles
vous allez voir c'est ce que j'ai fait
et puis on peut aussi à écrire
bien sûr mon herbier pour être sûr de ne
pas le perdre et voilà c'est terminé il
faut penser à mettre aussi des feuilles
blanches supplémentaires pour compléter
lherbier quand on va faire d'autres
balades et on a en autre rendez vous
également à noter aimé parce que si on
hésite à se lancer c'est pas toujours
facile au tout début la chapelle art
contemporain de clairefontaine en
yvelines organise un atelier dès l'âge
de 4 ans
les réservations là
sont obligatoires comptez 12 euros on
dit merci mélanie vous avez vous savez
donc ce qu'il vous reste à faire pour
votre prochaine balade dans un parcours
en forêt merci encore mélanie on passe à
notre agenda avec un dernier rendez vous
à noter ce samedi de juin rendez-vous à
gambais pour la grosse kermesse une
après-midi une soirée consacrée aux jeux
mais aussi aux concerts n'hésitez pas à
venir déguisés
aucun thème précis laissez libre cours à
votre créativité
le site loisirs est maintenant terminée
je vous retrouve la semaine prochaine
pour un nouveau numéro et je vous
souhaite un excellent week end
m
où